so you're saying Tyrone Woodley I saw
that and ask him when you're coming up
how old now are you wrestling with these
guys are you training with these guys
and if yes at what age did that start
when you guys are training together so I
came into Mizzou as an 18 year old as a
freshman Tyron was in his going into his
senior year so I had one year on the
team with Tyron I had two or three two
years with Ben and they were both like
my big brothers and I can tell you right
now Ben askren might be the exact
opposite of me when it comes to
self-image that dude thinks he that dude
thinks that he can do anything and it's
he is the most confident
person I have ever been around in my
entire life yes and I spent so much time
around him and I always felt out of
place and and there was even there was
even moments where I was mad at him or I
would lash out at him or because he was
just like it doesn't make sense to me I
don't understand why you don't believe
in yourself you're beating CP Slater
here by four points and all of a sudden
you gave yourself permission to lose
instead of giving yourself permission to
win and I'm like Ben I don't understand
why I can't win I'm just afraid to I'm
afraid to give myself permission to win
you know whereas a guy like him
I don't know how he developed that but I
sure am
studying up hard right now to be able to
instill in my children more like his
thought his thinking than my thinking
not cocky you're saying pure confidence
you're not saying he was God little bit
was a little cocky you know he rubbed
people the wrong way but in in UFC I'm
thinking how he was at 20. yeah for sure
and he had he had the fro and he would
he would talk trash and that kind of
stuff and I think you know not to go
back to to quotes but even even just the
the Nelson Mandela quote you know let
your own light shine so you so the
people around you will inadvertently let
their light shine you know don't be
afraid to be the best because because
other people might feel insecure around
you I think I also I also tried to
operate in such humility that it was a
detriment because I think humility is is
the most beautiful thing it's probably
one of the greatest traits that you can
possibly have but too much humility yeah
it's going to be extremely hard to be
extremely successful because you had you
know limiting beliefs is I believe what
it's called I think yeah I think there's
the intersection and kind of that that
fine line between limiting beliefs
Church environment where you raise in a
Christian environment I was raised
Catholic
um and then I you know I was actually
the one I got saved really in a
Spirit-filled church when I was 16 and
was one was the one who kind of started
bringing my family to a
non-denominational Christian Church got
it so sometimes that sometimes that
brings the humility where you you feel a
little bit uncomfortable being Shameless
and promoting and being self-promotion
you know like hey let me tell you here's
what I'm going to be doing because it
kind of comes from a it is one of the
values and principles uh in the
non-denomination to not be doing that
but in your world you're in today that
skill set pays a lot to be you know a
little bit Shameless about promoting
yourself yeah and but by the way when
you did it that one time when you won
and you came out and you said hey Connor
now you got it it was like boom boom
boom the way you said it but go Max so
when you're when you're wrestling with
the Tyron or what you're wrestling with
Ben uh uh are are they at this level
Superior to you or is it like by half
are you guys about the same when you're
going up against them are you are you
developing confidence saying I can hang
with these guys or at that level the
two-year difference between you and Ben
he was Superior to you yeah Ben Ben for
sure and Tyron as well but Tyrone was
more I became somewhat of tyron's uh
tyrants practice dummy because he knew
we were around the same way I was a 157
pounder he's 165 pounder and he knew if
he called me at 4am I'm there if I could
he calls me at midnight I'm there if he
calls me on the weekend I'm there so I
became that guy because I was once again
the walk-on and this is Tyron Woodley he
was a St Louis Legend he was a you know
couple time state champion from my home
city as well
um Ben Ben was in a league of his own he
was a couple time Hodge Trophy winner
which is essentially the Heisman of
wrestling
um and but Ben and I traveled Ben was
yeah Ben Ben was Ben is one of the best
NCAA college wrestlers of all time when
he came out how many game how many fight
win streak did he have I don't remember
what the number one he did well he
didn't lose until he didn't lose until
he came into the UFC Mazda was his first
loss and he was like 21-0 the one when
mazatol knocked him out in three seconds
with the need of the head was six yeah
all right
my bad brother seconds over here
uh you know but so Ben was in a league
of his own and those two guys wouldn't
exactly give you much confidence because
I always lost to them and they also had
the big brother they had the big brother
did you ever meet him did you ever beat
him I took Tyron down one time I took
Ben down one time I think maybe in a you
know five years wow so you so so so you
had the edge because you're 167 Tyran is
uh 175. you're going up against somebody
that's got eight pounds on you which is
teaching you how to go up against a guy
a bigger size than you and a little bit
older than you experience so it's kind
of helping you out that's yeah good
positioning for you yeah for sure and
even back back to your point you know
the the idea of of the walk-on what what
is the what is the thread of of success
because I talked to these young guys now
I'm training with I'm training with 22
year old guys right now I got Scar
Tissue older than a lot of these guys
I'm 36 years old you know and I just say
hey man don't think about you today
let's think about let's think about you
10 years from now you want to be where
I'm at 36 years old still doing what I'm
doing and I made a career and I'm able
to be able to take care of my family so
so with that going back to college
tyron's a you know he's not even to me
in in the sport of of wrestling Mixed
Martial laws I don't think you're a true
man until 30. that's that's my true
belief that's when I truly finally felt
like a man and maybe I'm a late bloomer
tyron's you know 22 at that time I'm 18.
he's got the Big Brother on me so I
wasn't going to beat him and he was much
bigger and I was a scrawny little
freshman
um but I started obviously to hold my
own a little bit more here and there but
it just takes time as well it takes time
in business your first your first
entrepreneurial Adventure compared to
your 50 and you're just a different
person you're a galvanized by the fires
that you have put yourself through in
business in relationships and for me it
was obviously physical in the work or in
the in the gym in the strength and
conditioning sessions in the Reps in the
drills and then eventually you know that
that body finally catches up to
hopefully the mindset that you're saying
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]